я люблю ще материку знайшли ходу
формування з проживанням розумні політики
в Україні
крім йому колосальну історію і при
мухін невдач у тему харчування і на
тягну ми говоримо про затвердження
українців цікавий і український та
малий акмол і Една не вбивайте, а на тлі
decide закону ківалова колісниченка там
з розумів ще ми тільки на початку ви
токах нашої постійної роботи я за
минулу так само
на мій данчик нашої комети цього святі
науки так ми будемо отак сам абу варівати
не тільки всю статтю про позов менших
принцип о-го-го бажаю для професіонала
вас і пологів шукаю
розум і steam хоче сказати.
зараз формується причина докінзу ти ж не
прелі до експертизи києва того виду вчитеся
та іншого поранити його законопроекту там і
за минулим і вас активно проти ти
запити ти приставки можна у регіоні
коли саме до граматики організації
студентки з та пологів шукай повертається та
законно хвилину йому для молоді для
перспективи і на моєму обожнювання його
змінила ти коротко частина маму приведе